and uh what else happened the lawyer
the lawyer that uh that represented
um a bunch of people
for he represented tons of indigenous
people
against a lawsuit against chevron i
believe it was
um for the for a oil field spill where
basically chevron had an oil spill uh
that affected a bunch of like indigenous
land and forestry in the united states
and he he fought against chevron uh back
in the early 1990s oh was this a young
guy what was he a young lawyer yeah and
then he just now they just now they're
like demonizing him he just got
sentenced to [ __ ]
six months in prison for
contempt of court
um
and it's insane like that's never
happened [ __ ] uh this guy this guy
literally just represented people
who lived on indigenous land who got
affected by an oil spill from chevron
and now he's going to prison for
contempt of court for six months [ __ ]
uh jeffrey epstein
didn't even go to prison he got a
[ __ ] sweetheart deal in florida for
[ __ ] molesting kids
on his first go-around yeah and still
[ __ ] that up and still [ __ ] up and
that's how sick he is he couldn't even
stop it just shows it just shows that a
[ __ ] american is run by corporations
and these corporations will get whatever
the [ __ ] they want did you read did you
read the book the pelican not the movie
but the did you ever read the pelican
brief no i haven't heard of it oh it was
i'm an idiot i don't know anybody no it
was john grisham
but it was before your time but it was
it was basically
the it was a um
a law firm
represented this this
it was like an oil interest and they
wanted to go into the everglades and
drill
for oil in the everglades but because
there were there were pelicans the
certain type of pelican and they were
endangered they weren't going to be
allowed to do it
they knew that their case was going up
to the supreme court like they tried to
do it they got stopped by this young by
this young
young a young couple or like a young
lawyer had stopped them but he had won
like he'd won the case and the case was
going to be be decided in the supreme
court but they knew
these two supreme court judges are a
problem for us they're going to vote for
the pelicans and we're not going to be
able to drill
but if they died
and
if they both ended up dying and there
were two new
um uh justices appointed that were in
our favor
we'll win the the pelican that we'll run
the we'll win the lawsuit and we'll be
able to get billions of dollars in oil
we'll be able to drill so they actually
exit they actually assassinate two
sitting supreme court judges to in order
to have these
new judges placed in in their place is
this it's a great book when did this
happen no it didn't happen it's just
called the pelican brief it's but i'm
saying it's a whole corporate greed type
thing it's not a real thing it's it's
fiction but there's a great story it's a
great they made a movie out of it
right that's all
well there's tons of stuff like that
like for instance um
uh for instance tom clancy wrote a book
called uh splinter cell
well he wrote tons of them but it's like
that
pretty sure it's also a book well um
what was it what was it was it the
debt of honor it was dead of honor where
there's a a japanese terrorist that
crashes a plane into congress right and
then like 10 years later you've got
people crashing planes into you know
buildings like there's like things in
these books that
that were like semi predicted prior to
that like that was that was this a
terrorist attack was to use a plane
filled with gasoline to crash into
congress wipe out all of congress
instead these guys hit the world trade
center you know whatever when did this
book come out
i wish it was about 10 years before a 9
11. wow but i mean that's connecting
dots here well i'm not saying there's a
connection i'm just saying that a lot of
times these things are well the 911
planes were those all
all of those planes were
they had flight paths they were going to
los angeles yeah so they were filled
with what they were filled with
yeah
unbelievable yeah whatever lots of stuff
going on but yeah so i mean he predicted
the whole hey did you ever read the book
um jennifer government
i i've read like three books my whole
life okay
well if you get locked up for ten or
twelve years you're you're allowed to
only have you on here because you've
read so many books and you're so
jennifer government's great it's like in
the future i read i read go dog
go uh
one fish two fish one fish two fish
redfish blue fish i read uh the cookie
monster cookie book
i only have a few books i read every day
so in jennifer government
these nike ends up doing what they call
gorilla marketing
where they end up hyping up these shoes
saying that there's a limited amount of
the shoes like there's only we're only
producing 10 000 of them they're gonna
have
500 here and 200 in this store so people
pack the stores but they don't have 500
they have like 5 000.
so by
they they hype it up and then what what
they do to make to give this the book or
the shoes street cred they hire people
to kill the first four or five people
that they get the
that end up getting the um the shoes so
they they shoot them steal the shoes and
that gives us
that gives them street cred so people
want them even more but they're saying
they're limited of maybe 10 000 but
really there's like
200 000 or a million shoes yeah but
people are still doing pumped supreme
that's what they do that's great
it's a great book
and you have to pay the police to
investigate the murders so your family
gets murdered you want you the person
that killed your daughter you want her
found so you refinance your house you
have to pay the police to track the
people down
because unless you can't pay for it you
can you have to pay for crime for uh
to pay for it and it'll pay for the
amount of the shoes are made in china
and the shoes actually are called
they're called
they're i remember they were called um
mercury's and they were they made them
for like a dollar 75 cents and they were
selling them for like
1500 or 1800 bucks yeah
the uh the rarity of it is what sells
the more hard the harder they are to get
the more people want them but the the
book has all the supply and demand well
the book to any typical business officer
the book has all these crazy supplies
and demands they have these crazy things
that are happening and they're happening
like then it's like that's not that's
happening this is happening like these
are things that
yeah it's called jennifer government hmm
i always thought they'd make a movie out
of it
you should make that movie there's a lot
of books that they should have made
movies out of but they won't because
this one was you know it's funny too
that you had a barcode like oh no
jennifer government has like a she has a
bar code right here oh and your surnames
are whoever you work for so if you work
for nike
then your name would be danny nike so
everybody's named like like this guy
works for the nra it's like his name's
matt nra
uh hit um you know then you've got
um you know
shane unemployed
that's how it is yeah right so yeah
concrete yeah exactly that's so that's
what and then when you change your job
you get a new surname huh the whole
thing is insane oh there are gangs of
kids that are like in a gang and they
out nike and mcdonald's will pay you to
tattoo their symbol or i'm sorry their
emblem is it emblem what would you call
it well go go whatever on you and so
you're basically with a gang people are
getting beat up because they're going
into mcdonald's and like you know you
mcdonald's or burger king i'm going over
here to mcdonald's and then they jump
and they start beating the guy
chick-fil-a [ __ ]
interesting
matt did you watch squid games
no and everybody told me i have to watch
it and i don't you know i do like the
concept he's uh the squid game director
creator is beefing with lebron james
do you know who lebron james is yeah i
know who
lebron james is he's beefing with the
creator of squid games because uh lebron
said the ending
was lame he's watched okay we got flea
flicker here we're watching the packers
game uh lebron
said that
the ending sucked the guy should have
gotten the plane went and saw his
daughter
and this quid game guy like made some
sort of statements like will you you
should remake the whole series and do
your own ending then lebron james
maybe uh
you'd have you know so now they're just
going back and forth now they're uh yeah
now i think that was all there was it's
funny yeah i don't know if there's
anything else but it's funny that it's
like a it's like an internet beef now